thank you for showing up here only two
days before Thanksgiving particularly in
as much as you could pick this up on
YouTube just as well as being here it's
very important to have the backs of some
heads so that people who look at the
video don't think I'm lecturing to a
completely empty room the book that is
the basis of this course is divided into
eight parts you probably have not made
note of any of the part names because
they're pretty feeble but we have four
parts for the first half of the course
and four parts for the second half of
the course and part four which we began
last week and will occupy this week in
the next two weeks is entitled
inter-regional patterns of culture and
contact that's almost impossible to
forget a phrase like that inter-regional
patterns of culture and contact this is
sort of soft determinism that is to say
it is it reflects the broad theme of the
world coming together so that the
preceding part was on the was on the
elaboration of cultural communities and
it dealt with specific areas and this
part is supposed to deal with how areas
come into contact this part does not
successfully do that particularly as we
will see next week when we have a
chapter entitled the Latin West which is
the single narrowest chapter in the
entire book in that it only deals with
with Western Europe a matter over which
the
authors engaged in some debate but this
chapter for this week is on the tropical
Africa and Asia I have raised as a query
for this week whether the word tropical
is like oriental a word invented by
Western scholars and writers as and not
for the purpose of but methey with the
effective result of of putting people
who live in tropical climes in a
negative position as people who are you
know exotic and lazy and don't have big
civilizations and are brown and have
other characteristics I would think that
one could get a fairly substantial
mileage out of doing to the word
tropical what Edward Sayid into the word
the Orient unless one feels that that's
already been done enough but the
question is what is it that you other
than that word that would provide some
sort of a theme for the for viewing
tropical Africa and tropical Asia in the
same chapter up to 1500
if you look at the index of the book and
you and this is something just something
that people who are addicted to counting
things do when you go to an index and
you're trying to find out what a book is
about it's often worthwhile to see what
are the things most frequently referred
to because then it saves you the trouble
of reading the book you can see whether
the book is going to be about things
that interest you or whether it's simply
going to be you know another history of
you know eleanor of aquitaine or
something so query who is the most
frequently cited not actually cited the
most frequently mentioned person in all
of world history according to the earth
and its people's judging from the index
the answer is Napoleon but Napoleon is
only one mention ahead of urban Battuta
Alexander the Great
Mohammad jenga's Khan you know they're
pretty important but hey compared with
even Battuta how in the world can you
put them even in the same sentence
because even Battuta is close to being
the most important person in world
history so I went and I checked one of
our rival textbooks by Bentley and
Ziegler and I said well how does
Napoleon fare there he's only mentioned
once even Battuta has mentioned 7 times
has 7 index citations he is outdone by
Alexander the Great
Hitler and Nikita Khrushchev but he is
really up there with
with you know world historical bad guys
or men of power whatever you want to
consume the master and you realize that
you know this person about whom you
normally read absolutely nothing at all
has a role in the narration of world
history that is literally unparalleled
because he didn't conquer anything
he didn't rule anything all he did was
write a book he didn't even have a
clever name from the book it's the
travels the riff Levin Battuta all of
the citations of imlah tuta in the earth
and its peoples are in the chapter that
you have read for this week because they
are all within a specific time period
namely a time period what he made his
his travels but he travelled in South
Asia in the Indian Ocean in Africa south
of Sahara and he wrote things that are
eminently quotable so you can say he'd
been Battuta met so-and-so and saw
such-and-such and this of course is
something that is not unique there are
other travelers but what adds to the
particular reports have been of
importance of evident atutor
in this respect is that he's not a
European so he's not Marco Polo he's not
William of rubric he's not you know John
of Planet Kartini he's not any number of
European travelers of whom we have many
many travel accounts he is a North
African Arab who who made these travels
and his book is very extensive the
Edition that I have is a little over six
hundred and sixty pages in a fairly
small Arabic typescript it raises a
question of what do you do with the
travel account there are essentially two
choices that you can that you have to
choose between one is to use it as a
kind of data source you know a grab bag
in the sense that you can go there and
find a quote you know you say gee I
wonder if it limit Oota went to Shiraz
and if so what he says about Shiraz
because I'm writing a little
encyclopedia article in the history of
Shiraz and therefore I can get a little
quote from him and Battuta so I look him
up and see
did he go to Shiraz guess he did and
then I can quote him or did he go to
Mali or did he go to Delhi and you can
quote him in the tooth that's one way of
doing it and that is the normal way to
do it the normal way to use this and
virtually every other travel account now
the alternative the choice not taken is
to look at the book as a whole and say
what was he doing why did he make these
trips
how is the time of his travels
distributed over the course of the book
what is the itinerary that he follows
and when you do that with Rueben Battuta
you get around there different result
first of all even though he is quoted by
virtually everyone who writes about
sub-saharan Africa out of the 660 some
pages about 18 of them deal with
sub-saharan Africa he went there
and spent very little time but he made
observations at a time when we have very
few alternative sources on the other
hand he has about 200 pages dealing with
his time in India
well that's 200 pages that's a lot and
he has a lot to say about India and
about the islands and the Indian Ocean
but most of the book deals with the
Middle East and 80 pages deals
specifically with a pilgrimage to Mecca
it is in fact one of the first books
that is structured around a narrative of
pilgrimage to Mecca this is a genre that
from this time on takes off and becomes
very very important so that particularly
in outlying areas such as Morocco or
India accounts of visits to Mecca become
a major genre so we have scores of later
manuscripts in various languages talking
about the pilgrimage to Mecca none of
which are ever quoted maybe not none but
very few of which because going to Mecca
is not big news whereas going to the
Maldive islands or going to Maui that is
that's more unusual on the other hand
you could say that the importance of a
journey is perhaps better thought of as
being proportional to the number of
people who go to that site than it is to
the to the number that happened to go to
very outlying areas so
when you when you go through remember
tooth and you see as I January which
spends good time in the least then goes
to Mecca then spells more time in the
Middle East and particularly goes up
into areas that are in the process of a
migration from from Byzantine
Christianity to Islam that is to say in
Anatolia and up into Central Asia there
you get very interesting materials but
they don't fit into a chapter that deals
with tropical Asia and Africa so here we
simply see him as someone who goes to
the southern he's suffering places he is
a very I can't say he's a reliable
observer because I wasn't there so I
don't know whether what he says is right
or not but there's a sobriety and a
seriousness to the accounts that
impresses most readers as being that of
a of a careful observer although he
often observes things that are less
interest to us than than race relations
or gender relations or things like that
for example he's very big phileas about
rank particularly in court affairs you
know what are the the lines of a rank
and privilege in various societies he
mentions extensively his time in the
Maldive islands
Oh which are in the Indian Ocean a group
of islands that are fairly numerous and
barely above water they are one of the
most homogeneous Lee ho ho managed in
one of the most same areas of the world
in terms of religion everyone is a
Muslim and they are very conscious of
that and they talk about who it was who
brought Islam to the baldies and they
say it's Apple better cap old better
bhaduri this is this could be the word
better berry in in Arabic script not to
be here
that little thing or it's a team or it's
a th or it's a y depending on what dots
you put on it this letter here is either
an R or a Z then we have another one
that's a be a T at TH or a y and then we
have another one that's an R or a Z and
then we have a good old familiar long I
or Y so they say okay you put dots here
and you have have better better you and
so you say okay this is the guy who
brought Islam to the Maldives better
berry well the eye on the end means it's
a over related to something so over
related to
so he must be a Berber you know oh and
even Battuta coming from North Africa
would have recognized this fellow
Moroccan at least by reputation as the
person who brings Islam to the Maldives
and you can't deny that Moroccans ever
got to the Maldives because they've been
but tuna got to the mouthpiece so so
you'll find a number of historical sites
that specifically say the Maldives were
converted to Islam by a Berber from
North Africa now someone else does it
and puts any and add something here and
makes this a bead this 80 that an R this
a y and this is Z they say I'm sorry
what's wrong this is the T this is the B
so if that's Tabriz all you do is change
the dots around and add a little tooth
that's what's with one tooth between
friends and you go from better berry to
tab it easy Tabriz is the largest city
in north western Iran it is in Iranian
Azerbaijan and so you will have other
historical sources that sources here in
what's in quotes I mean we're not
talking about modern conjectures about
all this that say that in Iranian from
northwestern Iran made his way down to
the Maldive islands in the middle of the
Indian Ocean and converted the people to
Islam so it's either a Berber from
Morocco or it is an Iranian from
Javanese or it's neither one and you
know if you checked neither one in the
box you probably came out right because
there is a city a seaport in Somalia
that can easily find on a map name
better better and it is to my mind
virtually certain that a Somali seaport
right there on the Indian Ocean is where
mr. Barry came from now the point of
this of this exercise and Arabic
spelling is that when you have but one
source and you have no instantly the the
source given Battuta sites was an
inscription in which the dots were not
apparently not not written and the
inscription has lasted through the 19th
century and then disappeared so nobody
can see it anymore
but when you're dealing with a single
source and you and you make an inference
as important as what are the trade or
travel patterns of people in this late
medieval period in the Indian Ocean you
really have to be fairly careful and
being careful is something that I don't
think the author of this chapter was or
I don't think he devoted as much care to
the precision of the writing as as he
should have first of all you know when
you are dealing with tropical Africa and
Asia there are certain things that do
that do lend together that do give you a
sense of some coming together and they
mostly have to do with seafaring and the
transit across the Indian Ocean about
which we have little information from
the time period that is specified how to
say before a 15:50 there are many many
speculations there are many things that
are known in the in general that are not
where the specifics are not known and
I've mentioned before and earlier
talking about the Indian Ocean the
phenomenon of the people of Madagascar
speaking the language originating from
Indonesia seemingly having reached
Madagascar before 500 AD
when it comes to the Indian Ocean
trading sphere we have a lot of
speculation and a paucity of information
let me take one topic in particular and
which is raised fairly extensively in
this chapter and that is the topic of
slavery slavery is a legitimate topic in
world history
it clearly is something of enormous
importance to many parts of the world at
different times it's also clear that it
is a word that covers a fairly
substantial array of of status positions
if you go back for example to classical
Indian texts dealing with me the legal
and political outlook of of Hindu
society in India you'll find that there
are that slaves are acknowledged as
existing and that there are certain
categories that that produce slaves for
example being a captive and war can
result in enslavement being
you know in being a child of a slave can
result in being having the status with
slave being sold as a slave by your by
your parents or some relative can result
in your being a slave being in debt can
result in your becoming a slave this
being related to if we more a lot more
often than not to gambling debts and
gambling was a notorious vice of ancient
India rather than the sort of debt
peonage that you have in later colonial
times there are no that's for leaving
one out but anyway the point is that the
slaves are are not a race that the
slaves are not a a category that comes
about in some you know singular fashion
and by the time you get to the period
covered by this chapter you've added one
more element to the slave situation and
that is military slaves people who are
brought in to the country to serve in
the military and who have slave status
what you do not find in particular is
the use of slaves for agricultural labor
on an extensive basis if this could be
wrong that is to say this could be a
lack of data
if you compare say ancient India with
Rome Rome appears to have had more use
of slaves for laboring purposes you know
on land and yet it it stands to reason
in in effect that slavery in South Asia
would would have certain limitations in
the in what we call the caste system and
which you know you have what we call the
caste system are two divisions you have
a division into varnas of which there
are four they're Brahmins Kshatriyas
fascias and shooters and then outcasts
people who are not there and then you
have jockeys jetties are sub groups
within each Varna and they are the
groups that the Portuguese use the word
Casta for so the caste system is is most
accurately seen as describing the
jetties of India but when you read
Indian primary sources the focus is on
the varnas because the you know the
status of a person is as much related to
the Varna as to the jati particularly
with respect to the two highest varnas
the the Brahmins
who were the priestly class and the
chakras
which is the warrior caste or the
warrior Varna among the jetties the
divisions are more often than not have
to do with occupation so you'll have
people who engage in a particular trade
will belong to a certain jockey people
who believe who belong to a who practice
a certain craft will belong to a jockey
and all the way down to people who who
sweep out latrines they will belong to a
certain jockey there's a strict
hierarchy of socialization and avoidance
that exists among these jockeys and in
this situation you have to ask yourself
how would a slave fit in who would own a
slave most information we have about
owning slaves has to do with rulers and
we can cite accounts of perhaps some
reliability talking about the huge
numbers of slaves a ruler might have
most often prisoners of war but in terms
of slaves becoming part of an economy
how would this how would this happen now
you can talk to specialists on India and
say you know tell me about a slavery in
pre-modern India and you're more likely
to get the answer I don't know anything
about that them than a substantive
answering because you don't have any
discussions in Indian sources beyond
these references to the slaves owned by
by rulers and that
relates to the whole question of how
many slaves were there is a big debate
there has for a long time been a debate
over the number of slaves that went from
Africa across the Atlantic Ocean to the
Caribbean and to North and South America
and you'll get a fair consensus tile
that maybe seven and a half million
slaves something like that then you have
the debate over how many slaves cross
the Indian Ocean and were they all
Africans or were even most of them
Africans what you will find in in the
chapter that's been assigned for this
week is a statement that says that
between 1200 and 1500 historians agree
that two and a half million African
slaves crossed the Indian Ocean that
works out to twenty thousand slaves per
year if you start looking into into more
detailed accounts of slavery you'll find
that when the British got into the
business of trying to terminate slavery
in the 19th century they estimated that
there were about twenty thousand slaves
per year that were trafficked in the
Indian Ocean area and that number
precedes that date to some degree but
does it go back to 1,200 more recent
work that's been done on the records of
the Dutch East India Company which
doesn't come into being until after 1600
has come up with with hard counts for
the numbers of slaves at the Dutch East
India Company themselves trafficked in
and they are dealing with a matter of Oh
as many as 1500 slaves a year and then
the question is were there other slave
traders who were dealing in vastly
larger quantities than the than the
Dutch and it doesn't appear to be the
case it's also very clear from the
records of the Dutch East India Company
and this is something again that could
have been brought up in this chapter
that slavery was not something that was
exclusively that exclusively involved
Africans that you had the Dutch you know
transported substantial numbers of
slaves who were of Southeast Asian
origin and substantial numbers of slaves
who were who became slaves living on the
east coast of India
figures have also been developed to show
in the early 1600s again this is a
century after the period of this chapter
but I think it was relevant
to show that the primary locus of slave
residence was in coastal cities but they
were not distributed in the countryside
but there are cities that the Dutch
dealt with like Batavia their major
centre in Indonesia there's a fair
number of coastal cities that have
populations that are 40 to 50 percent
slave populations so what what you
appear to be seeing is a coastal culture
in which slaves are a an important
commodity play a very substantial role
in the society but in the interior of
India much much less so now as for those
slaves that come from Africa prior to
1600 it appears that most of them don't
go to the Middle East or India but go to
islands in the Indian Ocean
so that islands like the Maldives or
Mauritius or reunion later on Islands
develop a a colonial
agricultural identity under the under
French and other European auspices those
islands gained a lot of their population
through the movement of slaves from
Africa now from where in Africa it
appears that the largest number of
slaves coming from Africa may have come
from the island of Madagascar which
means that they were people originally
you know with their lineages from
Southeast Asia rather than from mainland
Africa there were extensive Wars on the
island of Madagascar between local
rulers and the prisoners were frequently
sold into slavery
so the whole the whole edifice of
slavery I think is handled rather poorly
in this chapter because the way it looks
is that the Indian Ocean is sort of a a
mirror of the Atlantic slave trade with
Africans being exported from East Africa
for to be slaves in India and the Middle
East and perhaps in some cases as far as
China just as the slaves from West
Africa were going over to the new world
but I think that in fact Indian Ocean
slavery is a lot more a lot more complex
both in terms of where the slaves came
from and in terms of where they went to
and in terms of the degree to which they
integrated with the society it is it
apparently is a case that the people who
do the slave trading are not Indians if
it when you talk about Seabourn trading
in all the way back to the time of the
Vedas in the earliest phase of Indian
culture there has been a negative you
know burden placed on anyone who crosses
the black water as seafaring was
referred to you for a Hindu to cross the
black water produce impurity that had to
be expiated in some fashion or other and
as a to the degree that India was
influenced by the by the religious
outlook of of Hinduism or before the
emergence of Hinduism of Vedic culture
seafaring was a frowned upon activity it
raises the question as to how or rather
who was engaged in the movement of
Indian cultural influences away from the
South Asia for example in Indonesia it's
very clear that there was a strong
Sanskrit and Indian influence at a
certain early medieval period well we
don't know who was who the carriers were
and the issue is a reason of were they
people who who traveled from elsewhere
to India became integrated into Indian
society in some fashion and then brought
the Indian culture home or were they
Indians who went who went off expanding
and looking for places to spread their
culture judging from the history of
Buddhism in China and Korea it would
appear that with the spread of Buddhism
the the pilgrims who are most involved
are people from China and Korea who go
to India and come back with sacred texts
rather than Indians who are who are
leaving India it's a it's a vexing
question
and has to do with with the issue of is
it natural
let me put differently at the beginning
of the course I talked about common
denominators among societies but there
are certain things that appear to be
true of all societies and all times true
in the sense that they that they
manifest one or another version of of
some feelings such as religiosity or art
or something like that
and one of the questions is is it is it
characteristic of human groups that they
want to expand their cultural orbit
our human groups categorically
outward-looking
or categorically inward-looking or is
this a variable and some human groups
are let us say conquerors or Wanderers
migrators and other human groups stay at
home how would one tell it has been
often remarked that when you look at
modern data with where we actually have
some fairly concrete data that it
appears that there are people who stay
at home and people who leave Scott's
been for example appear to find Scotland
really boring and they go somewhere else
and Scott Scott's wouldn't show up
all over the world Egyptians not so much
Egyptians notoriously like to stay at
home I won't comment on whether that
seems reasonable after visiting Cairo
but but it is a commonly said of
Egyptians and then when you look at
people who do move and you ask why do
they move where they move and do they
bring their culture or do they adopt the
culture of the place where they where
they end up
why do Lebanese Shiites go to West
Africa where as web eni's Christians go
to North America or South America
you know we we don't have answers to
things like that but one of the
questions I think in world history has
to do with why with whether we can as
historians come to any conclusions about
why a particular culture spreads or the
means by which it spreads
for the benefit of those of you who are
watching the video there's a question
asked about about more recent phenomena
of migration or cultural influence you
know I I think that that a history
clearly fought as Americans and people
who are necessarily involved in American
history the history of migration is a is
a really gripping part of American
history and that nobody can ignore it it
has been recognized as a key element and
when you study immigration in American
history it necessarily brings to mind
the whole panoply of earlier and other
instances of of migration
supposing you live in a country that has
had no immigration and you've simply
been yourselves for as far as you can
tell kind of time immemorial does your
does your view of the world and of your
culture change substantially as it you
know as a result of that for example if
you are Danish and Denmark hasn't really
been on the cutting edge of world
conquest for a number of centuries now
but it has a very distinctive national
consciousness will your attitude toward
your culture when it is confronted say
with Muslim immigrants be very different
from the attitude say
of the British who were accustomed to
being Imperial overlords for for a
couple of hundred years and who might
react to Muslim immigrants differently
you know we have lots of studies of this
sort of thing in nowadays about how
people integrate or fail to integrate
how cultures react or fail to react
whether multiculturalism is a practical
reality or whether it is a utopian myth
but when you deal historically you tend
to deal with with artifacts where you're
looking at say an art practice that
originates in one place stands up
someplace else for example in the period
that this chapter deals with you have
the rise of the Delhi Sultanate in or in
India there is now a very good book
dealing with the Muslim Hindu
interactions in the area of art and
architecture during the period of the of
the Delhi Sultanate by a historian of
art at NYU whose name is not coming to
mind anyone know who he is
and we tried to hire him at Columbia and
didn't work but he looked at art in
Afghanistan and art in northern India
and he found that an enormous fluidity
so that you had Indian characteristics
drawing up in Afghanistan Persian
characteristics showing up in northern
India evidence of artisans from
different backgrounds interacting in the
creation of specific monuments and so
forth and you you look at it and his
evidence and say you compare it with the
with the period of the rise of Islam
where you have the integration into some
sort of a Muslim artistic synthesis of
practices from the Persian Society or
provincial Roman society and you say
well you know it appears that you know
amalgamating here in in two situations
where you have Islamic conquest that
cultures amalgamate rather rather
successfully on a kind of street-level
basis that you know people have to build
buildings they have to produce artistic
goods or goods that will sell in a
market and you get a blending of
practices this is not necessarily always
the case you know you can have rather
rigid divides between cultures instead
of it amalgamation and the question is
whether an amalgamation of cultures is
quitter there should be an emphasis
placed on this if I when I look at this
chapter on tropical Asia in Africa my
feeling is that this is that a better
unifying theme than the one that was
chosen ie the works of voluma Tudor
would be to talk about the extension of
Islam into what I call the Muslim South
and say everything south of the latitude
of Medina which is 25 north latitude I
define as a Muslim self and say in this
period 1200 to 1500 this is the period
of the great extension of Islam as a
religion into sub-saharan Africa
particularly the Sahel area into
sub-saharan East Africa into the Indian
Ocean into India although more in the
net in the north and in the south and
into Southeast Asia Malaysia Indonesia
and the southern Philippines and say you
know there is if we're talking about an
international pattern of cultural and
cut of culture in contact that is the
pattern that is the thing that is
spreading at this time and the
geographic locus of it is precisely the
geographic locus that even Battuta
focuses on namely the pilgrimage to
Mecca that would be that would be my
take on this I didn't write this chapter
as you may have guessed but that you
opens the author up to the critique of
is this overemphasizing Islam is this
giving a particular importance to
a intrusive religious tradition at the
expense of downgrading the local
traditions of West Africa East Africa
South Asia and Southeast Asia is there a
way to balance this this sort of this
sort of thing now in earlier chapters
when we talked about the spread of
religions we had the in the sense of the
benefit that the ancient pagan religions
and polytheism of the ancient period
simply disappeared ultimately and so we
don't have to deal with any jove
worshippers or you know Thor enthusiasts
and so forth these days and but when you
get to these these sort of late medieval
early modern centuries you you really
have this question of of the the grand
picture of the spread of Islam in these
areas and the the perfectly legitimate
and understandable desire of each local
society to to maintain and the
historical memory of its own particular
characteristics and how do you how do
you how do you do justice to that
certainly if you say it is that Islam is
the theme you get engaged in the whole
question for South Asia of Islam versus
Hinduism which then translates into
Pakistan vs India you know are you
saying that Islam is more important than
Hinduism because it is spreading and
Hinduism is let us say contracting
that's a very difficult position for a
history book to to find itself in
because one of the objectives of a
history book is to is to avoid political
controversy even perhaps while
consciously or unconsciously maintaining
stereotypes that are ultimately
political in character but uh so that
would be the theme that I would pick for
this chapter yeah now the question is
whether Buddhism suffered more than
Hinduism at the expense of of Islam
there is a debate on on whether or not
Buddhism was dying in India before the
Muslims came as I understand that most
South Asian historians feel that
Buddhism was well on its way out or was
diminishing before Islam came but that
is still had in Buddhist institutions
some of which were destroyed in the
process of Muslim a Muslim conquest why
Buddhism which after all originates in
India why Buddhism fails in India and
thrives in Tibet Mongolia Southeast Asia
China Japan Korea
that is a that's a very vexing question
I have not read any any history that
explains in the satisfactory way why
that came about and partly it's because
there's a great deal of a great deal of
ambiguity about what Hinduism was and
when it comes into being in other words
you have a ancient religious texts which
are the Vedas then you have a whole
series of religious of genres of
religious writing that are collectively
known as Vedic literature and you have
the brahmanas the Iranian cos and so
forth and all in Sanskrit and this
culminates in the Upanishads and the
Upanishads embody philosophical
reflections on the entire Vedic
tradition Nippon assad's more or less
form the foundation for for Hinduism at
a sort of a the religion of religious
intellection now at a social level there
is a development of Buddhism and Jainism
out of this tradition and it's carried
in other languages than Sanskrit and it
gains a certain popularity that
popularity ultimately is challenged by a
greater popularity by Hinduism but
whether it is something like what
happens in China where neo-confucianism
you know more or less pushes Buddhism
down to the popular level and keeps it
from being
the dominant religion after the rise of
the song or whether there is some some
other dynamic going on in India it's
just it's just very hard to tell now
with Islam when you get to the way South
Asian historians portray the becoming of
Islam
you get rather extreme opinions on both
sides one of the most common opinions
that you find expressed by Bible
historians
South Asia when I say opinions because I
don't think that they're they quite rise
to the level of theories is that the
Muslims came and threatened everyone
who's being killed with less they
converted to Islam and therefore they
converted people by the sword Muslim
historians deny that this ever happened
and yet the chronicles that exist will
often refer to the number of prisoners
taken in battle and so forth but that is
not the same thing as converting people
by the sword this is simply taking
people prisoners after a battle and
perhaps enslaving them the the emperor
Akbar becomes a Paragon for his
tolerance of Hinduism and you know a
couple of raids later a later ruler our
anxiety comes notorious for his Muslim
fanaticism it becomes a very complicated
you know competing set of stereotypes in
which Buddhism simply drops out of the
picture and doesn't get mentioned by
much by a bunch of anyone you have
certain legends about how Buddhism comes
to Tibet but that's a different story
this is all taking place after 1500 with
Akbar and Aurangzeb and that is one of
the awkward parts of this particular
chapter is the confinement to a period
of 1200 to 1500 which is not in
particular natural period you know why
why 1200 well it fits into the into part
4 chronologically but it doesn't have a
particularly good rationale otherwise
when you let me just say a bit more
about this awkwardness this week's
chapter on tropical Asia and Africa will
be followed by net in next week by a
chapter on the Latin West which is
basically our version of the old red and
RAF course you know Renaissance and
Reformation kind of implying that those
are still important which could be
debated then that is followed by a
chapter on maritime expansion which is
the old story of European exploration
democratized to talk about other people
sailing around not just Europeans and
they're all in the same timeframe so
we're all dealing with something that
ends all say 1550 or so you know
should the world have been divided up
differently and if you're going to say
that for the post Mongol period 1200 you
know you're dealing with the beginning
of the Mongols we already dealt with the
Mongols and the aftermath of the Mongols
now we're dividing up the rest of the
the rest of the old world according to
being in the tropics or being in the
Latin West or having to do with maritime
enterprise this chapter even though the
time period includes the period of the
Portuguese discovering the the route to
to the Indian Ocean around the Cape of
Good Hope and it includes the beginnings
of European I intrude into the Indian
Ocean they don't get mentioned in this
chapter because that sort of reserved
for another chapter should that have
been done
does it know what is the advantage of
doing it that way
there were there are other possibilities
if you you could concentrate exclusively
on the question of of the Indian Ocean
and leave out West Africa you could talk
about West Africa the western
Mediterranean and Portugal in Spain they
obviously fit very closely together
because of the history of European
expansion but we're sort of throwing the
the West African Muslims into into this
chapter you could talk about Southeast
Asia
and link it up with Polynesia the
Philippines and going up into South
China and maybe even as far as Korea and
Japan there are other ways to do it what
what happens when you're writing a world
history textbook is that these sorts of
questions get ironed out in author in
author meetings and you you decide how
are we going to divide up the world and
then you say well if we agree we're
going to divide up the world let's say
and have a chapter on tropical Africa
and Asia who is going to write the
chapter so somebody raised hand is I'm
going to write the chapter and now that
person is given some latitude okay
you're you're it for that chapter how
are you going to do it because we're
going to fit the other chapters around
it and because you're working in a
collegial enterprise you bend in the
direction of what a particular author
wants to do so for example for next week
with the laughs and west we had an offer
meeting which we said why are you only
dealing with Western Europe
why can't you throw in Eastern Europe
and he said I don't want to throw in
Eastern Europe I want to deal with
Western Europe I think that that's
enough it's important it's the
Renaissance Reformation 100 Years War is
you know Queen Elizabeth ain hey how can
you not have ad as a separate topic
regrettably there there is no at least
in in the experience of our textbook
writing and I think with other textbook
as well
there's no overriding compulsion to do
it one way or another and you end up you
know compromising on a lot of issues for
example there is a theory called
southern ization this is associated with
world historian that tough stain Linda
Schaeffer who in fact was the person who
began the project that culminated in the
book the earth and his people even
though she dropped out of the project
having you know after she began it
southern ization is the idea that at a
certain point the world sort of looks
toward areas farther south it's what I
call the history of the Muslim South
only she dates at three hundred years
earlier I associate it with the the
Mamluks the Mongols the end of the
Caliphate and the preeminence of the
pilgrimage she associates with other
sorts of things so you can even even
when you have similar theories they may
not dovetail with respect to to
chronology or causation or or sources of
evidence for this chapter but what we
really had ultimately was even magenta
and in my view that is something that
needs to be addressed in in the sixth
edition of the book which will be up for
discussion come January so that's all
for today
you